this is a review of programming memes
with george hotz
quick mention of two sponsors four
sigmatic the maker of delicious mushroom
coffee
and public goods my go-to online store
for minimalist
household products and basic healthy
food please check out these sponsors in
the description to get a discount
and to support this channel and now
on to the memes let me
ask you to do a meme review or inspect
some printed black and white memes
maybe give a rating of pass or fail like
binary
if if this is a win or a lose
these are mostly from the programming
subreddit
you don't like this one this doesn't
pass i mean you're like i could do it
straight up like pewdiepie meme review
yeah
there's this this this meme gets a one
out of ten
this is too much text only half-assed
looked
already already too much attack are you
gonna skip
on the text well what am i going i yeah
yeah i don't know about this i think
this this this plays on
bad stereotypes
is that all of memes i don't know no i
think no i think like
now this one this meme's much better
okay never spend
six minutes doing something by hand when
you can spend six hours failing to
automate it now this one i like
cries in powershell are you doing a
power shelf
do you do that yourself like do you uh
find yourself over automating of course
i mean but you learn so much trying to
automate
you know you could spend six minutes
just driving there instead of spending
you know
uh 10 years of your life trying to solve
self-driving cars that's true
that's the programming spirit of course
i don't know what that is
you know it's like you're trying to
overcome laziness you end up putting in
way more effort to overcoming laziness
than just overcoming it
78 000 up votes on that one jesus
okay mine doesn't have the oh wow oh
that's up there i say
this just yeah this is why i trust
programmers a lot more than i trust
doctors
it's like you like googling you like uh
doctors think they have some like like
like some like
divine wisdom because they went to med
school for a few years i'm like
yeah dude i understand i didn't google
this on webmd actually like i read these
three papers like
you know yeah i think i remember once
when i was uh let's say drug shopping
and um one of the doctors referred to
adderall as a schedule b
drug now i can't you know correct this
guy that's drug seeking behavior to an
extreme
um schedule two it's not schedule b but
you know
like your doctor you don't you don't
know that the dea gave you a pad to
prescribe you don't know about the drug
scheduling system like
like yeah yeah programmers don't don't
have that they just
outsource you do you think that this
becomes a problem if you outsource
the entirety of your knowledge to stock
overflow you write stuff from scratch
pretty well yeah yeah yeah they asked me
they asked me uh
on instagram they were like what's the
integral of 2 to the x
and i'm like look it up well the
integral of
e to the x is e to the x so it's like
something
like that yeah the same with wolfe from
alpha you just started looking it up
[Laughter]
yeah that's pretty good that's funny
that's the first thing that's the first
funny one
you do you do testing you do like
user on that user we give it a unit
testing yeah we do use that too yeah we
have we have
our regression testing has gotten gotten
a ton better in the last year
um now we're pretty confident if the
test pass
that at least it's going to go into
someone's car and do something
right versus in the past like sometimes
we merge stuff in and then like one of
the processes wouldn't start
right so you think that kind of testing
is still really useful for for
autonomously
not as much unit but like some kind of
um
got better words today holistic like
integration testing
the thing runs yeah that it runs and
that it runs in ci and that it like
doesn't output crazy values and then
actually we wrote this we wrote this
thing called process replay which just
runs the processes and checks that they
give the exact same outputs
and you're like this is a useless test
uh because you know
what if something changes well then we
update the process we play hash
right like this prevents you from if
you're doing something that you claim is
a refactor
this will pretty much you know it will
check that it gives the exact same
output every single time
which is good and we've run that over
like you know 60 minutes of driving
but that one's a win for you you get
past the 10 yeah
that's an eight out of ten now you don't
give anything a ten out of ten that's
that's a good meme
um
yeah yeah i mean you know this is why i
don't use ides that's just this is true
this is just true it's nice i gotta say
i mean this to me
is kind of funny because it it's so
annoying it is so annoying when i do
that's why i'm still using
emacs is because i d it's like clippy on
steroids it is
of course uh they're gonna make good
ones though i i always still wanna
this is a company i think i wanna do uh
and i've trained i've trained uh
uh language models on on python you can
train these like big language models on
python and they'll do pretty good job
like
reading checking for bugs and stuff so
yeah hope for that like machine learning
approaches for improved ids
yeah that's very interesting yeah yeah
but i think machine learning approaches
for
like improved like look at google's uh
auto suggestion in gmail
yeah like um oh yeah that even like the
dumb thing that it does is already
awesome
there's a lot of like basic applications
of like gpg three language model that
might be kind of cool
yeah i think that the idea that you're
going to somehow get gbt3s to replace
customer service agents
i mean really this reflects so badly on
customer service agents and like
why don't you just give me access to
whatever api you have you know
i don't know this this one is uh yeah
i just saw a picture i actually wondered
if it works at all
that's good that's good
[Music]
the last line is good okay thanks bye
no i'd rather you mine cryptocurrency in
my browser than using my speakers
yeah i feel that way about pop-ups too
just anything i mean those you can at
least block it's like you know what the
only thing i do want to auto play is
like youtube
what uh why do new sites start auto
playing their news
i don't i don't i don't get i haven't i
haven't been to a news site in
years sure i do not read the news like
like people
like like i still hear about the news
because people talk about it
like i've never been to a news yeah who
goes there
who comes to these sites and in fact
even on hacker news i'll always avoid it
if like the link is like a new york
times or cnn or
i guess i've read a few things um
but yeah those like the pop-up news
sites yeah those websites are broken
somebody needs to fix it that's at the
core why journalism is broken actually
it's cause like
the the revenue model is broken but
actually the interface like it's just
like i i have to i can literally i want
to pay the new york times in the wall
street journal i want to pay them money
but like they make it like to where i
have to
to click like so many times and they
want to do you have to have a login and
have a new york times password
yes and also they're doing the gym
membership thing where they try to
make you forget that you signed up for
them god so that they charge you
indefinitely like just be up front and
let it be five bucks and then everybody
would it's your idea which is like
just make it cheap accessible to
everyone don't try to do any tricks
just make it a great product and yeah
people like it everybody will love it
yeah
actually what i want to see also i've
seen them start to exist is adblock that
also blocks all the uh
recommendeds i don't want trending
topics on twitter
please get rid of it these trending
topics have zero relevance in my life
they're designed to outrage me and bait
me nope don't want it
you know one interesting thing i've used
on twitter i had to turn it back on
because
it was tough is uh there's there's
chrome extensions people could try is it
turns off
the display of all the likes and
retweets and all that
it's like all numbers are gone it's such
a different people should definitely try
this
it's such a different experience because
i've realized that i judge
the quality of other people's tweets of
course by the number of likes
yeah like it's not you know basically if
it has
no likes then i'll judge it versus one
that has like several thousand likes
i'll just see it differently yeah and
when you turn those numbers off
i'm lost at first i'm like what am i
supposed to think it
it's a beautiful thing it did it's right
and how much is it manipulated
yeah so it totally is but it's an
interesting experience
worth thinking about i found that so
actually i do i block you can
i do it with adblock i have like like
training topics anything that's global
and applicable to everybody i definitely
do not want i do not want to know what's
trending in the united states right now
it's always some like political agid
prop or like something it's agit prop a
lot of the times
but at the same time like to push back
slightly for me
trending like if there's a nuclear war
that breaks out
that's how they get you that's how they
get you and i just trust that if nuclear
war breaks out someone's going to come
to my friend will text you rental
attacks be
like you know yo hey are you going to
show up there or what right
yeah okay so if it's bad enough you'll
know yeah i did also try turning off
youtube's recommendations
but i realize that they do provide value
to me like the tail customized to you
yeah and yeah as opposed to a general
one like a trending one yeah yeah
yeah youtube does a pretty good job
so this one is about how stack overflow
can be really rough asking a question a
stack overflow
be like no no
i've never asked a question on stack you
never have uh it's rough
i don't comment okay i'm never if
someone if there's a comment on the
internet i just want you to know that
they probably do not reflect my values
well i mean there is some truth to that
too one of the documents that i make
everyone everyone a comma has to read it
it's linked from the thing is it's eric
raymond and it's how to ask smart
questions
yeah um and it's just like well you know
the quality of the answer you get
depends a lot on how you will phrase the
question to be fair i think yeah
the auto keyword is not is a uh
i think stack overflow likes it where
it's like
there is an answer there's not really an
answer to that right
that's a that's a great reddit thread
but some of the most interesting
questions are a little bit
ambiguous ambiguous uh yeah i do
i do this in interviews i ask ambiguous
questions and i just see how
i found that that's so much more useful
for gauging candidates than like
to see how they reason through things to
see just like what they think of and
like what language they use and whether
they show familiarity or not
what do you by the way just as a quick
aside
is there any magic formula to a good
candidate intelligence and motivation
intelligence and motivation yeah
motivation passion yeah
and you can see it through uh we just
conversation
um i always wish there was a test that
you could just online like a form that
can fill up
well okay so there's the old problem of
testing for intelligence is easy because
okay smart people can lie and say
they're dumb
but dumb people can't really lie and say
they're smart but testing for motivation
is is much harder so we do this we do
this we have a
micro internship we bring people in for
two days paid
um to come you know work on something
real in our code base
nice and we see like you know are you
just doing this as like a
job interview if you're doing this is
like okay i gotta like check this box
then yeah you're not a good fit
that's awesome that's a good idea and
then you see and you can be picky
and see like if there's a is there a
fire there like that
yeah we see and like now we hire a lot
of people uh you know who at least
like if you're coming to work economy
you're kind of expected to have read the
open pilot code
all right like the best candidates are
the ones who like read the code and ask
questions about it
like it's open source right the beauty
of comma is you don't need to be
hired by us to start contributing
true
yeah are you obsessed about resource
constraints
uh some not size i don't care about
bytes but uh
cpu cpu well cpu is watts and lots is
bad
lots lots of so we're gonna pump them
somewhere where we're lowering the cpu
time
people complain about the comma 2's
overheating um
we have a solution we're lowering the
cpu frequencies
we're going to shift that in the next
one but don't worry we've made the code
more than efficient enough to cover for
it
no that's yeah that's one way to cool
beautiful this is good i mean okay five
out of ten
which one the my code doesn't work let's
change nothing i do that all the time
that's the weird thing and it often
works
it's running stuff again i don't get it
i don't get how this world this universe
is programmed but
it seems to work just like restarting a
computer restarting the system
like this audio setup sometimes it's
just like not
working and then i'll just start off and
start turning back on and it just works
i interpreted this meme totally
differently
you interpret it as is in like this is a
good idea
yeah i interpret it as in i find myself
doing this all this is dumb
i just i just run it again i know it's
going to give me the same answer and i'm
not going to be happy with it but like
you know
i found it i did uh advent of code um
last december it's evan o'code's great
it's uh like
it's a programming challenge every night
at midnight for december
um yeah i'm proud of myself about how i
did on leaderboard um
yeah i found myself doing that all the
time like this has to be right i don't
understand
yep this is like this kind of you embody
this in some sense you've
uh you're able to i mean at least i've
seen you able to accomplish quite a lot
in a very short amount of time
it's interesting yeah sometimes i don't
know some of them like people don't
realize how much
like i cheated at twitch slam um you
know like okay
to be fair i did write that slam from
scratch on there i did not have like a
copy of it written
but i also spent like the previous six
months studying
slam so like you know i had so there's a
base there
sure um going into it whereas like with
these other things like
i don't have anything going into it and
people like why isn't it like twitch
slam well
you know so this one is just uh
you find this to be true it's just funny
at all
i find it three out of ten
yeah three out of ten there's a lot of
threes in there
this is a machine learning question yeah
true yeah i mean
this is the tension i get this i mean
sometimes this
meme pisses me off a little bit because
people that like
learn machine learning for the first
time and they're struggling with
like object detection and they think how
is this supposed to achieve general
intelligence
uh that's because you're just doing a
first intro to what uh
software 2.0 as opposed to like when you
scale things i mean you can
achieve incredible things that would be
very surprising
i mean it's the same thing with software
1.0 you know they they sit there and
they write hello world and they're like
how is this thing supposed to fly
rockets
right and it does yeah the thing is it
does just it just takes a whole lot more
effort than you you think
um i don't know but i i'm very um
you're bullish on neural networks
emotional neural networks i think neural
networks are definitely going to play a
component
i'm bullish on what neural networks are
which is a beautiful generic way
i was uh um
one of our one of our screening
questions is what's the complexity of
matrix multiplication
um and i was i was explaining this to
like like
why fundamentally this is true and then
i went a little further with and i'm
like you know this is neural networks
it's just like matrix multiplications
interspersed with non-linearities and
there's something so uh
the fact that that's such an expressive
thing and it's also differentiable
it's also quasi-con like it's convexi
which means like comics optimizers work
on it like
yeah well this isn't going anywhere of
course not yeah the question is
what are the limits of its surprising
power
but i think that we haven't seen the
loss function yet yeah we haven't seen
the right loss function
um you know it's going to be something
fancy that looks i think like
compression
and i haven't seen these things really
applied maybe there was that one paper
where they tried like surprised to solve
montezuma's revenge
but yeah there's a lot a lot of fun
stuff in rl that uh
it reveals the power of these things
that's yet to really be
understood i think so that's kind of an
exciting one
thank you for putting up with this
nonsense of a
paper-based meme review george
you